do you want to stay on the show
not necessarily no i think that i need
to move on i need to do my own thing i
think this should be the end
after nearly 13 years kailyn lowry is
saying goodbye to the teen mom franchise
i literally wake up every day and i'm
like wow i'm on tv and i have four kids
like what is life i i literally don't
know what it's like to
to not be on tv anymore but i also am
like is this real
kailyn made the big reveal during her
virtual appearance at the teen mom 2
reunion which had co-hosts dr drew and
nessa in total disbelief do you want to
stay on the show
not necessarily no i think that i need
to move on i need to do my own thing hmm
i'm not going to say goodbye to her
today am i i'm not going to say
i don't know i feel like we should
feel like we should
yeah this is like a breakup right now i
think this needs to be ready for this
kale i think i'm ready i think that we
just should part ways i think this
should be the end
of course caitlyn made her debut on 16
and pregnant in 2009 alongside her then
boyfriend joe the two welcomed their son
isaac in january that following year
isaac
you want some bacon we haven't
officially gotten back together because
we're still on shaky ground but right
now i have to put our relationship aside
because it's my first day of school
then in 2011 kaelin joined the cast of
the franchise's spin-off teen mom 2
where she's documented her growing
family in 2013 she welcomed son lincoln
with ex-husband javi they split in 2017.
then she started dating chris they've
since split but share son's lux and
creed you're so smart and you're caring
and you're a good big brother
and you're a good friend
right
[Music]
now that we've been in the public eye
for so long even if we were to leave the
show they still feel like they know us
the bigger picture is that we have a
good time with it we've met really cool
people we've we've inspired people we've
lowered the teen pregnancy rates and so
you look at the bigger picture you're
like okay i did this for all the great
reasons when e.t caught up with kaelyn
in 2020 after over a decade of sharing
her life on tv she opened up about how
she'll know when it's time to walk away
i guess
when it becomes more of a stress in my
life like
filming is stressful but not stressful
enough to walk i don't know as of right
now i mean i would continue as long as
they're
they're asking me to and as long as
people are watching and it's and it's
you know still what it is um
but tomorrow that could change so
we don't really know
and now she finds herself at the end of
her journey on the show i think i'm
ready i think that we just should part
ways i think this should be the end you
will be a huge loss because i have deep
affection for you and you know you
helped uh turn the the tide of teen
pregnancy in this country you helped do
that i hope so i hope i had a a small
part in that kaitlyn's exit comes just
days after mtv announced they're
rebooting the teen mom franchise by
combining the cast of teen mom og and
teen mom 2. but don't count kailyn out
for any spin-offs in the future because
she also told et this i think if they're
if it was a if it was the right fit i
definitely would do another show or or a
spin-off um i did marriage boot camp
before and so
um
that was crazy but yeah i think it's the
shoe it not the shoe if if the show was
a right fit yeah i would do it